Tatort Deutschland präsentiert den
dunklen Januar jeden Tag ein neuer
Kriminalfall ein tägliches Tatort
Deutschlands Spezial mein Name ist
skadame und ich wünsche euch eine
spannende Krimizeit hello und hier ist
wie immer eure Natalie Strauss moin und
euer Mirko Kasimir
Natalie sag mal kennst du den Fall wo
ein sportlicher mit 40er bei einer
Wanderung in den Südtiroler Alpen
hinterrücks mit einer Jagdwaffe ermordet
wurde
meinst du etwa den tätowierten
vollbartträger mit den Öko Klamotten und
der erste survival Ausrüstung genau der
Typ der selbst im Frühsommer nichts
besseres zu tun hatte als auf über 3000
m Höhe im eisigen Wind und Schnee herum
zu spazieren das übliche Haltner ja klar
kenne ich den Fall liegt aber schon eine
Weile zurück
der Wanderer stemmt sich gegen den Wind
seit der über die Baumgrenze hinausgegen
ist bietet nichts dem wilden Getöse mehr
Einhalt er sagt sich zwar immer dass es
im Winter schlimmer wäre aber so richtig
glücklich ist er nun nicht mehr mit
seiner Entscheidung heute noch so Hals
über Kopf aufgebrochen zu sein
es ist nicht mehr weit er muss nur noch
über den Kamm da hinten gehen das wird
der scharfen bis Sonnenuntergang und
dann ist auch schon wieder der Abstieg
dann kommen wieder die schützenden Bäume
und es wird wärmer sein er rückt seine
kratze auf dem Rücken zurecht und die
Fellmütze tiefer über die Ohren
okay dann mal weiter
der Wanderer stöhnt ab und zu auf die
Knie tun ihn verdammt weh die Arthritis
schlägt in letzter Zeit immer heftiger
zu dann kommt noch der Druck in der
Brust oben drauf sein Herz wo
ja das ist die Arteriosklerose von der
recht einseitigen Ernährung und zu guter
letzt noch das tiefe Husten gerade beim
Aufstieg von seinem ständigen
herumhängen im Rauch zu Hause
der Wanderer dreht sich abrupt um
irgendetwas stimmt nicht seit er mit
seinem zügigen Aufstieg aus dem Ort im
Tal begann hat er das Gefühl verfolgt zu
werden
vielleicht einer der jüngeren Typen aus
dem Ort vielleicht sogar der welcher ihn
gestern abend erst angeschrien und dann
mit dem Messer bedroht und verletzt hat
er schaut auf seine Hand die Wunde sieht
soweit okay aus das wird schon wieder
das schlimme ist eher der Junge Typ hat
seine Position als Chef im Ort in Frage
gestellt
dabei ist der einsame Wanderer der
erfahrenste unter den Bewohnern der
sagen wir mal ökochkommune aber eben
auch schon recht alt sein lässiger baut
und die coolen langen Haare der
Waschbrettbauch und die Tattoos täuschen
nicht darüber hinweg sein Gesicht zeigt
die vielen Sommer im Hochgebirge in
jeder Falte
was soll's er verschwindet jetzt mal für
eine Weile ins Nachbar Tal woanders den
Sommer verbringen und den Hobbys fröhnen
hört sich eigentlich nicht schlecht an
also der Wanderer ist ganz allein auf
der Grenze zwischen Österreich und
Südtirol unterwegs
auf 3.200 Metern Höhe ist ein sehr
dicker Gletscher die Temperatur dort
deutlich unter dem Gefrierpunkt und das
schneit es stürmt ja also der Typ ist
quasi so eine Art Reinhold Messner nur
so ein bisschen in die Jahre gekommen
und mit so einigen zipperleihen aber
sonst nichts weiter trotz seines Alters
sucht er aber immer noch Stress mit den
jüngeren die Frage ist jetzt nur woran
ging es denn jetzt eigentlich vielleicht
so ein typisches Männerding ja um Frauen
oder irgend so eine andere Rivalität die
sie da miteinander austragen mussten
irgendwas politisches aus der Kommune
vielleicht man weiß es nicht der
Wanderer hat bisher keine Namen schlecht
weil wir ihn nicht kennen
in dem kleinen Ort im Tal aus dem er
kommt Leben nicht viele Leute lassen wir
es vielleicht 100 Personen sein die
Berghütten in denen gelebt wird sind
recht geräumig und so leben dort alle
mit allen zusammen eigentlich ganz
gemütlich man ist streng ökologisch
unterwegs Klamotten werden meist selbst
hergestellt und man setzt auf
Eigenversorgung etwas Landwirtschaft ein
paar Haustiere der Fischfang und die
Jagd sind auch genehmigt räumlich und
vor allem zeitlich liegt das Dorf etwas
ab vom Schuss es gibt noch lange kein
Telefon oder Strom hier
im Prinzip ist man in der Kommune soweit
glücklich und kommt gut zurecht
aber Streit gibt es dennoch immer wieder
die jungen wollen es auch mal zu was
bringen und die älteren wie unser
Wanderer stehende Sache im Wege dazu
bestimmen die alten Wehr mit wem
zusammen ist und vieles mehr außerdem
hat man sich im Ort aus so special
skills spezialisiert also sie stellen
eigene kupferwerkzeuge her unfassbar
wertvoll sind die Dinger weil es
natürlich Handarbeit alles Einzelstücke
und hier nicht wie bei uns made in China
und man ist auch im Waffengeschäft
involviert man hat sich spezialisiert
auf
hochleistungs-bögen für eine besonders
lautlose Art der Jagd im Ort ist es auch
gar nicht mal so ungefährlich weil
faktisch jeder bewaffnet ist und Polizei
oder Gerichte das kennt ihr keiner hier
werden die Dinge unter sich geklärt
da ist doch irgendwas der Wanderer
schaut sich erneut um aus dem Gletscher
und dem schneeragen immer wieder dunkle
Felsformationen hervor
oder nicht deine Bewegung der Wanderer
ruft in die Richtung der Felsen
keine Antwort
naja die Steinböcke queren auch diesen
Kamm hier vielleicht war es eines der
Tiere eigentlich eine gute Beute aber
frisches Fleisch brauchte heute nicht
und sein selbstgebauter Langbogen ist
noch in Arbeit nachdem sein letzter
kaputt gegangen ist
okay dann halt ein schnelles Picknick
der Wanderer sucht sich eine
windgeschützte Felsnische Klasse hier
lässt es sich aushalten er hat alles
dabei um sich ein kleines Feuer zu
machen auf Kraxe und matte sitzt der
bequem
sehr gut das geräucherte Hirschfleisch
ist lecker und das Obst aus kleinen
Äpfeln und Beeren rundet den Snack gut
ab eigentlich wäre eine Runde schlafen
jetzt gut aber er muss weiter es ist
auch viel zu kalt wer weiß wie das
Wetter wird
dann doch lieber weiter über den Kamm
der Wanderer rappelt sich auf dann hört
er wie Steine Poltern ins Rollen kommen
da ist doch wer
er lässt seine Ausrüstung liegen und
steigt zum Felsen hinauf um zu schauen
was da los ist der Unbekannte Wanderer
hat schon Recht wenn er vermutet dass er
verfolgt wird sei der zügig aufgebrochen
ist folgt die nämlich die ganze Zeit
schon sein junger rivala sein Bad ist
noch schwarz und seine Kniegelenke sind
noch richtig gut geölt ja nicht so wie
die unseres unbekannten Wanderers mit
dem langen Leben in den Bergen dem
Jungen Rivalen reicht's aber nicht wenn
der Wanderer für den Sommer die Kommune
verlässt denn wenn er im Herbst
zurückkommen würde geht es wieder Streit
um alles und jedes und das muss aufhören
und da gibt's nur einen Weg der Wanderer
muss sterben aber niemand darf erfahren
der Wanderer klettert auf einen
Felsvorsprung und muss lauter rülpsen
hey man sollte einfach nicht sofort
loslaufen wenn man gegessen hat
der Sturm hat sich gelegt der Himmel ist
blau der kann weit in die Teller schauen
aber am Horizont ziehen graue Wolken auf
er muss weiter
und da sieht er ihn da ist sein junger
Rivale vom Abend der der ihm auch die
Hand verletzt hat also ist er ihm die
ganze Zeit gefolgt und steht nun nur
einen Steinwurf weit entfernt stumm und
mit wütendem Blick vor ihm
was will der bloß der Wanderer ruft ihm
zu dass er sich verdrücken soll sonst
setze es was aber der Typ hebt nur
seinen Langbogen an spannt einen Pfeil
auf und zieht auf ihn sag mal spinnt der
Wanderer hat seine Ausrüstung leider
unterhalb des Feldes liegen auf dem
steht Mist
blitzschnell dreht er sich um und will
wieder hinabklettern doch dann zerreißt
ein Schmerz seine linke Schulter der
Junge Rivale des Wanderers fackelt nicht
lange und schießt mit einem Pfeil des
langen Bogens auf den Flüchtenden der
hat keine Chance der Pfeil ist schnell
und spitz er durchdringt die dicke
Pelzjacke die Haut und das Schulterblatt
des Wanders er zerfetzt zwei wichtige
Blutgefäße und bleibt dann hinter dem
Schlüsselbein stecken der Wanderer
stürzt unsanft in die Tiefe genau auf
seine Lagerstelle breit mit dem
Brustkorb auf einen großen Stein und ist
unmittelbar bewusstlos der Junge Rivale
haftet dem stürzenden Wanderer hinterher
er sieht ihn auch gleich bei euch links
neben seinem Lagerplatz liegen der rührt
sich nicht langsam tritt der Rivale auf
den Wanderer zu ruckartig sieht er ihm
den Pfeil aus dem Rücken wobei die
Spitze abbricht verdammt das wird später
eine Spur einen die sein
aber egal er hat keine Zeit denn es wird
bald dunkel der Rücken des Wanderers
hebt sich leicht lebt der Typ etwa noch
das kann doch nicht wahr sein
nun
elegant ist es nicht aber der Rivale
nimmt einen Stein er zögert kurz reißt
die Fellmütze vom Kopf des Wanderers und
schlägt kräftig zu
er Wanderer ist tot das mit dem Stein
hätte sich der Rivale sparen können denn
sein Opfer wäre innerlich so oder so
schnell verblutet der Rivale überlegt
noch kurz ob er ein Teil der wertvollen
Ausrüstung des Wanderers mitnehmen soll
das ist einiges dabei was ziemlich teuer
ist und er auch eigentlich gut
gebrauchen kann aber jeder am Ort würde
die Sachen erkennen und damit wissen
dass er den nervigen alten um die Ecke
gebracht hat und das ist ja nicht so
förderlich am besten einfach alles so
lassen wie es ist denn so sieht's nach
einem Unfall aus wenn man nicht ganz so
genau hinschaut aber am Ende kommt
sowieso keiner mehr so schnell hier hoch
auf den Berg dann geht der Rivale zurück
in die Kommune ob der Wanderer wohl
vermisst wird ja das wissen wir nicht
denn dazu ist nichts bekannt die Sache
ist auch schon ziemlich lange her um
genau zu sein
5.300 Jahre
ihr wisst natürlich längst wer der
Wanderer ist heute hat er einen Namen
Ötzi was wie aus einem ZDF alpenkrimi
klingt ist vermutlich so oder so ähnlich
abgelaufen und bis heute ein Cold Case
und ein ganz schön langer kalter
codecase Ötzi lag mehr als 5000 Jahre in
und auf einem Gletscher Schneide ein
gefroren taute wieder auf und gefror
wieder und wurde so zu der perfekt
erhaltenen feuchten um mir das
Einfrieren und das Auftauen hat mit der
trockenen hochgebirgsluft dafür gesorgt
dass der Leichnam gut erhalten geblieben
ist bis er dann am 19 September 1991
entdeckt wird und zwar von den beiden
deutschen Urlaubern Erika und Helmut
Simon die finden ihn während einer
Bergtour im Bereich des diesen Jungs im
Schnalstal auf
3210 m Höhe die Simons melden dem von
dem Hüttenwerk der semiauen hatte der
wiederum die österreichische Polizei und
die hygienischen karabinieri einschaltet
erst geht man von einem verunglückten
Bergsteiger aus am nächsten Tag macht
man einen ersten Versuch den leicht
Namen zu bergen aber es ist schwierig
den Toten aus dem Eis frei zu bekommen
nur ein uralt wirkendes Ball wird
geborgen witzigerweise kreuzen zwei Tage
später die beiden bekannten Südtiroler
Bergsteiger Hans Kammerlander und
Reinhold Messner auf Messner sieht die
ganze Angelegenheit vor Ort und eine
Skizze des Balls ich muss sofort klar
dass die Person hier schon ein paar
hundert Jahre länger liegen muss
vielleicht ein bisschen unterschätzt
würde ich sagen nach einer ziemlich
rustikalen Bergungsaktion mit
Hubschrauber und Polizeikräften wird
klar das eigentlich Historiker oder noch
besser Archäologen vielleicht auch
Mumien Spezialisten sich der ganze Sache
annehmen sollten eine erste C4
Altersbestimmung ergibt dass der
Leichnam
5.300 Jahre alt ist und damit aus der
späten Steinzeit und be den Kupferzeit
stammt einer Zeit also in der die
Menschen schon sesshaft waren Handwerk
Jagd und Handel betrieben und vor allem
erste Werkzeuge aus Kupfer hergestellt
haben wie das gefundene Beil bestens
zeigt
die ganze Sache mit dem Eismann geht
pressemäßig steil und um die Welt ein
Wiener Journalist verpasst der Mumie
wegen des am Fundort angrenzenden
Ötztals den Namen Ötzi damit hat die
Welt einen richtig gut erhaltenen
Vertreter ihrer Steinzeit Vorfahren
mitten in Europa es wird noch mehr bei
der genaueren Untersuchung der
Fundstelle gefunden ich zähl mal ein
paar Sachen auf ein noch nicht ganz
fertiger Langbogen ne Pfeilen ein Messer
mit Feuerstein Klinge dazu ein Gerät zum
Schärfen aus Bein und Holz
Gamaschen oder Beinlinge aus Leder und
Fell Schuhe aus Fell Leder basteln recht
warm und stabile schnurrt
ein Lendenschutz aus Leder plusgürtel
ein dicker Pelzmantel und eine warme
beerenfellkappe ein birkenrinden
Behältnis für glühende Holzkohle zum
Feuermachen wie man später experimental
archäologischeres bekommt Reste einer
kratze und Köcher für die Pfeile und
kleinere Utensilien für die Jagd als sie
war also sehr gut ausgerüstet und
bestimmt nicht zum ersten Mal in der
rauen hochalpine Gegend unterwegs mit
Sicherheit nicht Ötzi war erfahren aber
für die damalige Zeit schon recht alt
und physisch verbraucht die
Wissenschaftler schätzen die Person
Ötzis auf 45 bis 50 Jahre mit knapp
einem Meter 60 Körpergröße bei einem
sportlichen Gewicht von 50 Kilogramm die
forensisch medizinischen Untersuchungen
haben zudem ergeben dass Ötzi kaputte
Kniegelenk hatte verstopfte Arterien ein
ruiniertes Gebiss und laut verschiedener
Merkmale in Bezug auf Knochenbrüche und
Hautveränderungen ein recht stressiges
Leben mit einigen Entbehrungen
gelebt haben Menschen wie Ötzi damals in
mittelgroßen Gemeinschaften Sippen und
Gruppen alle zusammen in festen Häusern
mit großen zentralen Feuerstellen
weshalb hört sie auch ordentlich Ruß in
der Lunge hatte aber das hat wohl damals
niemanden interessiert
alle wurden mit geräuchertem Fleisch und
fischsaat auch wenn nicht gerade
Jagdsaison war Tiere wurden mit der
gefährlichsten Waffe damals gejagt mit
dem Langbogen selbst große Tiere konnte
man damit aus bis zu 30 Metern
Entfernung tödlich treffen die
Pfeilspitzen waren aus Feuersteinen auch
Silex genannt unfassbar Schaf und sehr
leicht aber man goss und schmiedete auch
schon Kupfer was man aus Oberitalien
importierte daraus wurden Äxte zum
Baumfällen und Hiebwaffen hergestellt
vergleichbar ist der Wert einer solchen
Axt heute sicher mit einer voll
eingerichteten Werkstatt eines
Handwerkers also irgendwas im
sechsstelligen Bereich
Ötzi muss wohl habend und anerkannt
gewesen sein sonst hätte er so ein
Werkzeug nicht besessen vielleicht war
auch genau das sein Problem alter Mann
und wohlhabens dabei noch relativ fit
und nicht willens den Staffelstab oder
die Arzt weiterzugeben die Verletzungen
die man an özilskörper bei den
Untersuchungen in den letzten
Jahrzehnten fand sprechen dafür dass er
öfter gekämpft haben muss Rippenbrüche
des Nasenbein gebrochen und dann noch
die frische Verletzung an der Hand die
eintrittswunde und die Pfeilspitze fand
man dann übrigens durch mikroskopische
Untersuchung der Mumie und durch Röntgen
und CT Aufnahmen und spätestens dann war
klar dass er sie einem Verbrechen zum
Opfer gefallen war naja und auch was den
Tatort betrifft da er alles noch wie
gerade verlassen herum lag und selbst
wertvolle Gegenstände zurückgelassen
worden spricht für die These dass der
Mord wissenschaftlich politisch und
persönlich motiviert war der oder die
Mörder wollten den Ötzi loswerden und
den nicht beklauen vielleicht war ja
auch Ötzi der Fiesling und hat sich in
der Dorfgemeinschaft was zu Schulden
kommen lassen vielleicht selbst jemanden
umgebracht und sich dabei die Hand
verletzt vielleicht ist der Mann im Eis
nicht grundlos gestorben aber es musste
dann ohne Aussehen Geschehen ganz
heimliche eben reine Spekulation wie so
vieles fallen aber sehr spannend auf
jeden Fall
Ötzi gibt uns durch sein erhalten
geblieben sein einen tiefen Einblick in
die steinzeitliche Kultur der Region
seine Tätowierungen Drucker
beispielsweise an Stellen die ihn
schmerzten vielleicht in der Hoffnung
die leiden dadurch zu lindern eine
Tätowierung war zum Beispiel auf
Brusthöhe und siehe da als sie hatte
Gallensteine sehr schmerzhaft und nicht
wegzubekommen jedenfalls damals nicht
genauso gab es Tattoos an anderen
Gliedmaßen der Mann hatte aufgrund
seines Alters so einige gesundheitliche
Baustellen und daher ging man auch eine
Zeit lang davon aus dass Ötzi vielleicht
in einem Ritus geopfert wurde weil es an
der Zeit war
aber schießt man jemandem der freiwillig
stirbt in den Rücken wohl eher nicht die
These mit dem Mord aus Rache aus
Eifersucht oder einfach einer neuen
Rangordnung wegen ist vielleicht die
wahrscheinlichste und das lässt uns an
diesem Fall nicht los jede neue
Erkenntnis der Wissenschaftler und
Wissenschaftlerin zur Steinzeit kann
auch die Zusammenhänge um Ötzi neu
beleuchten und sie uns anders bewerten
lassen es ist ein Cold Case was den
Mörder betrifft aber ein ganz heißer
Fall für die Wissenschaft
das hast du sehr schön gesagt Mirko ich
finde es auch total faszinierend dass
man einen Jahrtausend Jahre alten Mord
allein daran erkennen und deuten kann
anhand der Dinge die das Opfer bzw die
Mumie bei sich getragen hat und der
Verletzung die man bis heute
rekonstruieren kann es ist der Wahnsinn
was alles rekonstruiert werden kann ich
meine man weiß sogar was er zuletzt
gegessen hat was er zum Frühstück zuvor
am Tage zu sich nahm man kann den Weg
skizzieren den er durch die Berge nahm
und sogar sein Ziel vermuten aber
ausgerüstet um weiter zu machen hatte
einen neuen Bogen in Arbeit hatte seine
Garderobe ausgebessert er wollte gehen
aber man wollte ihn nicht ziehen lassen
na ja man weiß es nicht aber die Zukunft
kann und wird mit Sicherheit immer
wieder Neues über die Vergangenheit
bringen und so lässt uns ein
Jahrtausende Jahre alter Fall bis heute
nicht los und gibt uns einen Einblick in
dein Leben vor unserer aller Zeit wir
danken euch fürs Zuhören ja und wir
freuen uns auch schon auf die nächste
Episode mit euch gemeinsam bis dahin
euer Mirko und eure Natel die
faszinierende Geschichte von Ötzi haben
wir mit Hilfe des Südtiroler Archäologie
Museums erzählt so wie das Portals der
Region Ötztal auf dessen Webseite
ötztal.com gibt es auch gute Tipps zum
Erkunden der Region in der die
Gletscherleiche gefunden wurde Redaktion
Stefan Netzeband und Antonia Haier
Produktion serdarinis